[Music]  what was that  honda yes dear are you using your powers  to turn on the light  yes dude hello me sweetheart  what do you see only your lovely rose  bushes  that's all are you using your night  vision vision  i assure you my love i see nothing of  this you have absolutely no reason  no  you were saying  [Music]  so what's a single gal like you doing  rattling around this big how  well i assure you i'm married to a man a  human one  [Music]  we are an unusual couple  oh i don't think that was ever in  question  we just don't know what to expect  howdy neighbors hey buddy  wanda what's up who are you  i don't know  this is not home then let's fight for it  well i think we handled that well  [Music]  bye